you have written a book and I
congratulate you thank you that is a
heart and his heart in this book you
investigate ethnic stereotypes and you
do it with a lot of honesty and a lot of
acuity on your oh thank you
let's start with the Irish you talk
about the IR people are people
it says yeah well just talking about you
know how we are like we're very shy like
first of all they would say Sigmund
Freud you say the Irish are impervious
to therapy Andy right at this
conversation okay but anyway he's German
so what you know and it's because a
whole life no not because why he's
German I'm saying back to what I was
talking about it is uh because our whole
life is being called out on every little
you know being criticized constantly was
that this whole show I don't know if you
can even hear that at home but I think a
toilet just fell over behind the curtain
the couch collapsed a while ago you know
whatever listen I don't might be the
last one we do so enjoy it folks
yeah I like to cut if we can cut around
my Irish thing it's already not doing as
well as I think I got a bad vibe about
it I love that you're um I love that
you're self-hating about your Irish hunk
that is so Irish of you exactly yeah
sorry what I want to say better because
Irish people don't use a word like meta
it's a little pretentious
you you understand just is also a little
pretentious
yeah you used your Irishness as a secret
weapon to get girls and I wish I knew
how this worked because during my single
days my Irishness in no way help me get
girls how did it help you well what I
would do is I was literally Lauren I
would go to bars and I'd pretend to be
I'd talk like this and I was basically
Ireland rose from I mean I tell them my
name was column I kind of in call I
because it was close to college when I
was really drunk if somebody said hey
Ralph I wouldn't turn around right right
right
so but basically I was an IRA guy I
didn't say IRA oh really all right I
wouldn't say that right I would just be
like well the troubles Northern Ireland
they call it the troubles right and I'm
kind of in a fugitive status kind of a
bartender fugitive guy poet yeah bring a
little book I always had like a little
play or something
you know yeah actual with me I'm not
saying it worked every time
I know but you're saying you're saying
that you would happen you would effect
on Irish accent the crowd judge me like
this is the electric he's got any game
whatsoever
back in the 80s this was game yeah so
you're talking to her girl just be I'm a
girl right now all right all right okay
you can be the girl god I can't believe
I pretended I was the girl girl girl you
the closest thing to getting closer
every year so did it work for you you
actually got women that thought that you
were kind of a cool terrorist well yeah
I mean girls love a good accent I mean I
don't know the quality that they were
where I was at the time really being
honest but uh you know it was all it was
a numbers game was in her breast game
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please